>> Tucker: NO SURPRISE.
YOU’LL KNOW IT FOR TWO YEARS
SINCE DONALD TRUMP FIRED HIM, HE
HAS MAINTAINED HE DID ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG AT ANY LEVEL, HE
SAID DONALD TRUMP IS A DERANGED
MAT BAND LIKELY A FOREIGN AGENT
AND THAT HE JIM COMEY IS THE
EMBODIMENT OF MORAL RECTITUDE,
THE LAST HONEST MAN IN
WASHINGTON.
IF YOU ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO
TWITTER, YOU SAW HIM MAKING THE
CASE EVEN TODAY.
WITH THE RELEASE, WE CAN SAY
DEFINITIVELY IT IS A LIE, THE
REPORT PROVES THAT.
IT IS A DEVASTATING.
AT THE REPORT SHOWS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION, HE IS SHOWING A
PARTISAN POLITICAL AGENDA AND HE
DID IT IN THE MOST SLEAZY AND
FELINE POSSIBLE WAY.
PUBLICLY HE CLAIMED HE MET WITH
A NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT IN
JANUARY OF 2017 IN ORDER TO GIVE
HIM AS MUCH INFORMATION AS HE
COULD.
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL WITNESSES,
THAT ACCOUNT IS FALSE.
HE TREATED THE INTERVIEW WITH
THE PRESIDENT AS AN INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING OPERATION, HE STASHED
A SECURE FBI LAPTOP SO HE COULD
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN WRITING A MEMO
AFTER IT CONCLUDED.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE WHOLE THING
WAS A SET UP AND IT WAS ONE OF
MANY.
IN THE END, HE WROTE SEVEN MEMOS
LIKE THIS, AT LEAST TWO OF THEM
CONTAIN INFORMATION THE
GOVERNMENT LATER CLASSIFIED AS
SECRET BUT HE LEAKED THE
INFORMATION NONETHELESS.
IN THE WORDS OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, BY NOT
SAFEGUARDING SENSITIVE
INFORMATION OBTAINED DURING THE
COURSE OF ITS FBI EMPLOYMENT AND
BY USING IT TO CREATE A BLOOD
PRESSURE FOR OFFICIAL ACTION, HE
SET A DANGEROUS EXAMPLE FOR THE
OVER 30, 35,000 FOR MANY FORMER
FBI EMPLOYEES WHO SIMILARLY HAD
ACCESS AND KNOWLEDGE OF PUBLIC
INFORMATION," ALL OF WHICH IS
PUTTING IT MILDLY.
HE WAS THE MOST POWERFUL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN THE
COUNTRY, THERE WAS NOTHING HE
COULDN’T DO.
HE USED HIS POWER FOR POLITICAL
ENDS AND THERE’S NOTHING MORE
CORRUPT THAN THAT.
IF WE SUSPECTED THAT ALREADY.
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO, HE
ANNOUNCED IT TO THE WORLD IN
FACT.
IN AN APRIL 2018 INTERVIEW WITH
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS, HE
ADMITTED HE HID THE ORIGINS OF
THE STEELE DOSSIER FROM HIS
BOSS, THE PRESIDENT.
>> DID YOU TELL HIM THE DOSSIER
HAD BEEN FINANCED BY HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
>> I DIDN’T THINK I USE THE TERM
STEELE DOSSIER, I JUST TALKED
ABOUT ADDITIONAL MATERIAL.
>> DID HE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT?
>> THAT IT HAD BEEN FINANCED BY
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS?
IT WASN’T NECESSARY FOR MY GOAL
WHICH WAS TO ALERT HIM THAT WE
HAD THIS INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: IT WASN’T NECESSARY
FOR MY GOAL, IT WOULD CUT
AGAINST HIS GOAL.
IN THAT SAME INTERVIEW HE
SUGGESTED THE MOST SENSATIONAL
AND LEAST LIKELY PARTS OF THE
DOSSIER MIGHT IN FACT BE REAL.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT THESE WORDS
WOULD COME OUT OF MY MOUTH BUT I
DON’T KNOW WHETHER THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS PEEING ON EACH OTHER IN
MOSCOW IN 2013, I DON’T KNOW.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS SLANDERED
UNINTENTIONALLY FOR POLITICAL
EFFECT -- THINK ABOUT IT.
THAT MAN ONCE LED AN AGENCY IS
TERRIFYINGLY POWERFUL AS THE FBI
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WHO
CAN REALLY BE SHOCKED BY THAT?
JOHN BRENNAN ONCE RAN THE CIA,
JAMES CLAPPER WAS DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
LIKE COMEY, BOTH MEN ARE PROVEN